retournons nous maintenant sur les
responsables au plus haut niveau
bien des questions se posent en effet il
n'ya t-il pas politisation des étudiants
contestataires que faire pour que le
calme revienne dans les esprits et puis
il y à tous les étudiants qui ne pensent
eux qu'à travailler passer et réussir
leur examen
va-t-on assurer éventuellement leur
protection il existe un secrétaire
d'état aux universités c'est une femme
madame saunier séité ecoutons-la
l'arrêté n'invente rien il invite
simplement les universités qui ne l'ont
pas encore fait ou qui ne l'ont pas fait
suffisamment à présenter des projets de
nouvelles formations
alors vous avez veillé sur cette antenne
en particulier pas de travail pas de
diplôme à la fin de l'année alors on est
à deux mois des examens et que vont
faire les étudiants si on ne leur donne
pas de diplôme les diplômes nationaux
pour être délivré exige que des
enseignements et des contrôles des
examens de contrôle soient régulièrement
assuré j'ai je me suis entretenu de ce
problème à midi avec les présidents
d'universités qui sont très conscients
des difficultés qui se présenterait si
les grèves se prolonger trop longtemps
mais jusqu'ici il n'y a pas de perrine
et comme recteur vous aviez la
réputation d'un négociateur est méritée
de talent est ce que vous allez vous
servir de cette réputation pour essayer
de régler cette crise autrement dit
est-ce que les négociations est ce que
vous allez rencontrer les étudiants le
parler avec eux essayer de régler
rapidement ce problème
eh bien écoutez j'ai rencontré les
étudiants déjà avant pâques j'ai
rencontré des associations étudiantes
pendant les vacances de pâques j'ai déjà
des audiences prévues dans les semaines
qui viennent et ils avaient été décidés
à la dernière conférence des
associations étudiantes que nous
reprendrions ce problème de l'année
en application de la réforme du second
cycle à la conférence les associations
étudiantes fin avril est certain nombre
de l'association étudiante qui doivent
se rendre à amiens cette semaine on dit
qu'elle me ferai part des résultats de
leurs concertations d'amiens